foreign
absolutely Wild
[Music]
All Creatures big and small share a
primary goal survive
[Music]
beyond the famous beaches
hidden from Land and Sea lies a watery
Wonderland
but Florida's swamps are no playground
for the animals living here it's a
Savage Paradise
foreign
[Music]
every year millions of tourists flock to
Florida the funny thing is
a third of it is underwater
foreign
make no mistake America's playground is
still Wild
just past the theme parks and planned
communities
predators are hungry for a Kill
[Music]
for almost any animal
the swamp is a scary place
[Music]
the Gin clear waters of these spring-fed
swamps team with a vast diversity of
life
from the tips of ancient Cyprus
to the river's Muddy Bottom
[Music]
the Backwoods of Florida are ruled by
dragons
no Predators patrolling these Waters
the American alligator
is their Supreme Lord
[Applause]
full-grown Gators may only eat about
once or twice a week
[Music]
that could be as many as 2 million
Ambush kids
the alligator is a finely tuned killing
machine
they are powerful swimmers
[Music]
using their tails for propulsion
[Music]
a fee for guidance
their hide is military grade
water is their element
stealth their method of attack
[Music]
the gator clamps down on its victim it
drowns
[Music]
foreign
the most fearsome part of this ancient
reptile is its mouth
designed to rip off Limbs and edible
chunks of carcass without
tearing teeth
over the course of a lifetime a gator
can go through two to three thousand
teeth
[Music]
graceful and mysterious
whitetail deer Gather in weary herds
amongst the Spanish moss
last century deer in Florida only
numbered around twenty thousand
but with abundant food and transplants
from other states
this population has boomed to over seven
hundred thousand
nobody will miss just one
A Relic from the time of the terrible
lizards these two are ancient
adversaries
for over 150 million years
alligators have been ambushing prey
practice makes perfect
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
this time he just misses
the deer's quick Instinct triumphs
[Laughter]
eventually the deer must return for
water
when he does
the gator has the weaponry
finish the job
[Music]
no alligator is born a swamp King
[Music]
they must evade countless deadly foe to
reach Royal status
foreign
[Music]
these new hatchlings could live up to 50
years in the wild
but they'll have to survive their first
year
okay
the hard truth is this
only one in ten Gator hatchlings will
escape death
[Music]
baby Gators are a delicacy
for a host of Florida's Wild
both above
and below the water line
[Music]
none is fearsome as a full-grown King
notorious for cannibalizing their own
kind
for now the princes are in protective
custody
few in the swamp are bold enough to take
on the matriarch
for young make brief forays
to explore their dangerous playground
[Music]
but their days of Discovery under her
watchful eye
are nearing an end
[Music]
Gators
to beat the odds
see his first birthday
he'll have to escape the swamp
surprising array of predators searching
for a meal
[Music]
Florida is much more than just a
vacation
beyond the property lines it's a secret
jungle
[Music]
the largemouth bass stalks the sunken
snags of the clear waters
[Music]
this fish's legendary mouth makes it an
unlikely assassin
[Music]
the bass possess excellent vision
ready to attack
[Music]
and sensing the slightest disturbances
in their domain
a frog tries to escape
but even a sprightly swimmer like this
has no chance against a speedy
Largemouth
[Music]
[Applause]
the bear seats his frog legs
cold
in fact it'll devour just about anything
that doesn't eat it first
including Baby Gators
a gator Prince not much larger than the
Unlucky frog
wanders Beyond his mother's gaze and
heads out for an open River Sprint
one day he'll rule the Florida swamp
if he can make it past the Largemouth
[Music]
[Music]
it's an ambush from Below
[Music]
one Prince Has Fallen
another Apex Hunter eliminated
call it a preemptive strike if you will
or just call it lunch
Central Florida gets a whopping 70
percent of its rainfall in the wet
season
the Deluge from Summer to fall keeps
water levels High
foreign but when the wet season ends
the hunters and the hunted will share
precious little space
several months into the dry season
watery Havens vanish
[Music]
channels dry up
and ponds disappear
[Music]
what was once a pool of life
is now a dried up field of naughty
Cypress knees
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
spoonbills ducks and more
concentrate in Shallow pools as they
wait for the rains to return
[Music]
oh
of course the effects of dry season are
still settling in
[Music]
there will be Predators coming to share
these crowded Waters
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
must make his way to a new Watering Hole
and new sources of prey
[Music]
[Music]
Gators can move quickly on land but only
for short bursts
this search for a new watery home is
long and exhausting
[Music]
the gator gapes its mouth open to cool
off
[Music]
his ambushability is most effective at
the water's edge
[Music]
it's unlikely he'll eat again until he
gets there
relief at last
[Music]
his new quarters are filled with rivals
they'd rather rule their own domain but
it's the dry season and bodies of water
are hard to find
of course there are other new neighbors
the king is anxious to meet
nearly 3 000 pounds of bite force is an
awesome weapon against any prey
or turtles in the swamp it's not the
hardness of the shell that might save
them from a Gator's Jaws
but rather the curves Mother Nature has
bestowed that give the turtle a Fighting
Chance
foreign
for the little guy
foreign
but of course even the best design can
only hold out for so long
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
there's no shortage of creatures on the
hunt in Florida's swamps
feeding starts with a crayfish
the most important part of this
Balancing Act
crayfish serve as the essential Link in
a complex Aquatic and terrestrial food
chain
unfortunately the hard shell of this
lobster-like arthropod is no match for
its numerous predators
like this masked Marauder patrolling the
water's edge searching for the swamp's
most plentiful snack
[Music]
but while the raccoon dies he must be
cautious or he'll become the next meal
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's hard to take this character too
seriously
[Music]
the bulging eyes and boldest figure the
North American bullfrog is not Florida's
most intimidating inhabitant
but creatures not wary of this prolific
Hunter will pay the ultimate price
the bullfrog employs a sticky
blisteringly quick tongue to snatch its
victims
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
he's an improbable Predator but don't
underestimate him he'll eat anything you
can shove in his mouth including a
Wandering Gator hatchling
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
bustling backwaters the leopard frog is
a smaller version of the bullfrog
and although the leopard frog is an
accomplished hunter in its own right
it would be wise to avoid sitting at the
family table with its larger cousin
bullfrogs are cannibals
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
European settlers introduced feral Hogs
to the swamp
they are intense breeders
reaching sexual maturity at just six
months
and multiplying like wildfire
they have few predators in Florida
[Music]
but there is one
[Music]
and around here
there is a huge price to pay for
trespassing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
like a Croc grabbing a wildebeest in
Africa
Gator tears the hog apart in a death
roll
All Souls are forewarned
don't graze too close to Florida's
swampy Edge
[Music]
[Music]
water levels are at their lowest
[Music]
but the rising temperatures mean A
Change Is in the Air
[Music]
[Music]
a dark Horizon signals the arrival of
the first big thunderstorm of the season
[Music]
the rains have returned
[Music]
predators and prey disperse into the
expanse
a welcome relief from the claustrophobic
web of peril
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Kingdom of the alligator is restored
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS are ectothermic
they rely on external sources to control
their own body temperature
it's a beautiful day to bask in the
Sun's Warm Glow
but it's also a beautiful day
for an ambush
the water moccasin AKA cottonmouth is a
pit viper using two heat-seeking pits
between the eyes and nostrils to hone in
on heat signatures for deadly accurate
strikes
foreign
mouths are primarily active at night but
like the young Gator they love to bask
in the sun which maintains their body
temperature and also speeds up
metabolism for digestion
bad news for the hatchling
foreign
the Venom destroys tissue and prohibits
blood from clotting the victim will
bleed out
the cottonmouth will dine
[Music]
now only one Gator Prince remains
thank you
[Music]
here in the Florida wild
just 20 miles from Disney World the
young are constantly Under Siege
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
late spring
Rising Waters and Rising temperatures
mean one thing
the struggle for dominance
[Music]
mating season
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
Gators will gather in large numbers for
a chorus
below the water line This bone creates
tense Sound Vibrations
the result is one of the great
phenomenon of the swamp
the water dance
[Music]
[Music]
the water dance is a show by males
looking to attract a female
[Music]
[Music]
after all the Bluster of violence
the end game is a subtle and gentle
affair
which will produce a new generation of
hopeful Hunters
[Music]
[Music]
with a perilous season under his belt
the sole remaining Gator Prince has only
one thought
must eat
with the instincts of a supreme predator
The Yearling attacks with gusto
this little guy has scored a hearty meal
[Music]
just upriver
the iconic King all swamp hatchlings
hope to become
[Music]
as unfinished business with an ancestral
foe
[Music]
[Music]
just a short drive from the Exotic Sands
of South Beach Florida's swamps host a
diverse ecosystem boasting colorful and
deadly characters
foreign
creature in the swamp shares a mission
make a living
[Music]
out here that means find yourself a bite
to eat
but don't end up on anyone else's menu
there is one creature let's always
guaranteed a seat at the head of the
table
[Music]
the Apex
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the time of year when mature
Whitetail males tussle for dominance
during the Run
and a young deer grazes by the water
[Music]
before he realizes is ventured too far
into the Kill Zone
of the Lizard King
[Music]
today's special is venison
the strike is lightning quick On Target
and without Mercy
foreign
[Music]
the waters have stilled and it calm
envelops the swamp
the cycle of Life completes another year
out here
just beyond the reach of civilization
[Music]
The Yearling Gator is one of the few of
his kind who has made it this far
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
ERS will pursue him for several more
years
[Music]
if he can survive across the seasons
he'll grow to four feet
no longer at their Mercy exclusively a
hunter
[Music]
joining his fellow Kings
always lying in wait for their next meal
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]